well i was sat down on the sofa with my
dad and um we were looking at pictures
remember on sunday and he said what's
different what's difference between you
and me and i said well you've got medals
on and he said well you'll be getting
one of them soon
that is brilliant fantastic well
congratulations we're absolutely
delighted for you just remind us remind
us about um uh the tent in your
adventure
so i also i started this because my
neighbor rick and brought she cancer but
before he died he gave me a tense and i
wouldn't have an adventure in it so i
wanted to raise money for northern
hospice he took such good care of him so
she wanted to say thank you in the
biggest way i could
and how much did you raise and how many
nights did you spend in the tent to
raise that money
i'm still going one i'm still in the
tent luckily
and i've raised over 680 000 pounds
including gifted i mean that is
incredible 680 000 pounds and you're
still in the tent so how many nights is
it now
i reckon it's just
40
just over that
so say that one more time we just the
wind blew away your answer
i think it's just over 640
640 nights has there ever been a moment
when you thought you know what now might
be the time to give up
there have been a few times but i've
never
i thought there have been a few times
where i wanted to go in but i've just i
haven't i've i've stuck my guts got
terminated and just kept on
going put your head down and kept going
well done you and mark you must be
incredibly proud aren't you
so proud i think every parent is but
this has just been a tremendous uh well
nearly two years now for max and we're
very
grateful for the opportunity and
grateful for the money you've been able
to raise for the hospice
yeah and the hospitals are incredibly
grateful as well aren't they um i
remember speaking to them and they were
they were just over the moon mark
yeah it's
they lots of hospitals have faced a
really hard time with lack of
fundraising in the last 18 months
because of covid
and max has made a big difference to
north devon hospice and enabled them to
maintain a normal service around without
having to lose staff or lose bets
which has been a huge difference to them
so max tell me what your plans are for
oh we seem to have lost them have we
lost them can they still hear us max
tell me what uh your plans are for 2022
maybe you can switch your camera back on
as well there we go there we go
that's all right tell me about your
plans for the for the new year
uh well so far we're gonna do the big
camp out again
um so hopefully we're gonna encourage
more people to get involved
uh we're gonna get people who did do it
last year we're gonna hopefully get them
to get their families and friends
involved so we just want to make it
bigger and better
brilliant we've got some more of the
pride of britain award winner going to
camp with him as well to celebrate it
fantastic so it's not just you uh uh
doing the camping you're encouraging
other youngsters too as well which is is
really fantastic and well done again
we're uh we're all really delighted for
you it's well deserved and i hope you
don't have too many stormy nights in the
tent